قال ايه اعداء مشنقا لقاتل سلمى بهجت
فقدام ثلاث شهور في مصر فالجميع ينتظر
الحكم على الجاني في احدى الجرائم البشعه
التي اسفرت عن ذبح طالبه سلمى بهجت جهرا
وسط الجميع وفي ضوء النهار لتصدر محكمه
جنايات الزقازيق لجماع الاراء حكمها على
المتهم اسلام عادل بالاعدام شنقا
افاده تقرير مستشفى الامراض النفسيه
والعصبيه بالعباسيه بسلامه قواه العقليه
والنفسيه واكثر ارتكاب الجريمه وفي الوقت
الراهن وعدم معاناته من اي امراض نفسيه
وقال محامي سلمى بهجت فتاه الشرقيه ان حكم
الاعدام الصادر في حق قاتلها اسلك صدور
الجميع فهو حكم عادل من الدرجه الاولى
واضاف ان لمحامي المتهم الحق في تقديم طعم
ولكنه يتوقع رفضه وتنفيذ العقوبه
جنايات الزقازيق باعدام المتهم اسلام فتحي
بالاعدام
نافذه في انحاء متفرقه بالجسد حتى فارقت
الحياه والسبب هو رفضها الارتباط به فاترف
في الجلسات السابقه انه بدا بتهددها
بالاكل لو فضلت مصر على رايها موضحا انها
كانت دليل في مرات بسبب الخوف وتعاود
الحديث معه لكنها سرعان ما تجدد رفضها
بينما كان حددها كانت ترد على تهديده
بانها هتبلغ الشرطه ثم تطلب منه الابتعاد
عنها
واضاف انه توعدها الا انها توقفت عن
معانده ايام الامتحانات لكي تتفادى شر
لانها كانت تعلم انها لن تعاود اللقاء به
بعد هذه المده
وعن تفاصيل يوم الجريمه لفت الى انه اتصل
بها بعد اخر يوم من الامتحانات وذكرها بما
حدث لفتاه المنصوره وهددها بنفس المصير
الا انها لم تستجب له فما كان منه الا انه
وجه لها في ذاك اليوم طعنات قاتله او
ذبحتها
[موسيقى]